Hayward's look guys my name is Ayana and
welcome back to my opengl series so
today we're gonna be talking all about
the renderer and we're gonna be writing
our first renderer which is pretty
exciting so if I all we have is in our
main file we've basically just got a
list of well classes that get created
and then later get bound and then get
drawn and it's just a little kind of a
mess and none of this is going through a
central pipeline which is really the big
issue that we have here it's still
perfectly fine for us to do something
like this but well instead of us
actually telling someone hey I have some
data I would like a drawn we're having
to do all of that work and that's a
problem for a few reasons first of all
it's bad because we're doing all the
work every time and if we want to render
something again well we have to make a
draw call for that and we have to go
through that kind of pipeline all by
ourselves again and again and again
which is bad because we're repeating
code it's error-prone it's also just
annoying all those problems and then
later when things get more complicated
and we have multiple rendering targets
or even something simple like blending
we have no kind of central glue that
ties everything together and actually
keeps everything organized and
debuggable and and running smoothly and
that's kind of where the renderer comes
in the renderer is like the factory
where we say here are some parts I want
you to make something for me I've
literally made that up on the spot but
you know what I guess it works so we're
gonna stick with that so basically the
idea here is fairly simple we have a
bunch of data in the form of like a
vertex buffer an index buffer a shader
whatever and we want to be able to give
that to someone and say hey this stuff
that I'm giving you I want it to appear
in the screen please and that's kind of
what the job of a renderer is now of
course it gets a lot more complicated
matter and we can tell the render a lot
of things but to keep it simple our goal
for today is really just to move away
the last remaining OpenGL call that we
actually have inside our main file if we
take a look at our code you can see that
pretty much all of this is abstract away
I mean we have like the vertex array
vertex buffer we've got index buffer
we've got shader we've got all this
stuff that is just complete
we abstracted away into our custom
classes however well we I guess we have
to open jail calls we've got beat jail
clear which should be handled by the by
the renderer and then we've also got
destroy elements so this is basically a
draw this is something called a draw
call as we've discussed previously it's
where we actually tell OpenGL I want you
to take what it was bound and just draw
this on the screen
somehow and that's what GL draw elements
does that should be something that is
taken care of by the renderer as is that
clear thing but the clear things kind of
a minor thing which we'll probably get
into later anyway how are we gonna do
that
well we're gonna start by making a
render of class and then inside that
render of class we're going to be
writing a draw function which basically
takes in a bunch of arguments so the
data that actually needs to draw
something and then draws it on the
screen and from that approach even
though that might seem like a really
simple thing we can grow that into into
something extremely complex and
extremely powerful so let's get right
into the code and check that out so the
first thing I'm going to do is right
click on source here get add new item
gonna make a header file called renderer
H and apparently I've already got the
render order H and recipe B yep that's
why we put all of our opengl stuff so
that's great so inside our renderer by H
I'm just gonna make some room here and
actually make a class called renderer
now whether this class should be static
or there should be a singleton or
anything like that that's it's up for
debate I mean some people like to
actually make this class a singleton and
make sure there's only a single instance
of that some people don't like to do
that because maybe they might want to
have multiple instances of the renderer
that's perfectly okay it's not me the
approach is really wrong it's just how
you want to do it we're just gonna make
this not kind I'm not gonna make every
method here static or anything like that
we're just gonna treat it as if we can
have multiple instances of this if we so
choose to that might be something you
might want to do if you have multiple
layers or something like that inside
your actual like graphics application
but there's no reason for us to kind of
go every board and just start making
everything static here so I'm just gonna
treat this as if it was a normal class
so our first goal is really just to make
a function called draw which takes in a
bunch of stuff so let's think about what
we actually need to draw something in
OpenGL well we need a vertex array we
need an index buffer and we need a
shader that's
we know so far right the vertex array
actually has the vertex buffer bound to
it so we don't need to worry about
vertex buffers at all but we do need to
have that index buffer the vertex array
of course as I mentioned and also a
valid shader so those three things are
really all we need now the index buffer
has the index count and if we kind of
pass in an index buffer into this draw
function we can kind of assume that we
want to draw that entire index buffer
because if we wanted to draw like a
partial index buffer would probably pass
in an index buffer which just had a
partial set of indices so over here in
draw I'm going to write vertex array I'm
going to pass all these by reference by
Const reference so vertex ravy a Const
index buffer IB and then Const shader
reference shader cool so there we go and
we can make that Const as well since we
won't be modifying anything into the
renderer I'm going to include all of our
classes here vertex array index buffer
and shader and that's looking pretty
good to me so in
render or CPP I'm going to write that
function so void R and draw draw it's my
little sister wedding for me remark as
Const as well and now we can actually
move out draw call here so let's go back
to application and see what it is we
actually need to move so we had this
vertex array binding this index array
binding and this shader binding now
what's interesting here is we're
actually setting a uniform so how is
that gonna work with our draw function
well we'll come back to that later but
for now let's just travel of this code
I'm going to go in to render or dot CPP
let me just play these other files gonna
paste that in here like that don't worry
about the set uniform so we have our
shader binding our vertex array binding
and our index buffer binding and then
finally back in application we'll steal
that GL draw elements just like that and
so we'll do GL call GL draw elements
triangles now instead of six we're gonna
have index buffer don't get count
unsigned int I think we assumed that
this is always going to be an unsigned
int as you can see here with the data so
we will just basically hide code this to
be unsigned int but in the case of you
may be having unsigned short as your
index type you might want to actually
pull that out of the index buffer or
where or wherever you're storing that
and
finally we're drawing everything as
triangles for now we will definitely get
into kind of different modes of
rendering in the future but for now it's
just going to be triangles because
that's what we're doing okay cool so
everything looks pretty good in our code
you can see that compiles just fine
we're not going to bother
unbinding any of this in a more
traditional I kiss whole concept of
unbinding I really should make a video
dedicated about that about this but like
unbinding stuff in opengl not strictly
necessary it is useful for debugging I
will say that but and it might reduce
some bugs
maybe but ultimately speaking on binding
stuff in OpenGL is just a waste of
performance you really need to do that
because before we draw the next thing
we'll be binding all this stuff anyway
so there's no real point more kind of
complex systems might have bite like
unbinding in debug mode and then in
release mode the unbind calls just do
nothing that's one option and we might
implement something like that if we were
actually making a game engine but for
now we're just gonna write our code like
this and it would be fine you could
probably argue that it would be wiser
for me to actually just put on binding
code here because again we are strictly
kind of talking about OpenGL here we're
not really writing a game engine so we
probably don't really care about
performance or anything like that I do
like to keep my card kind of lean though
and just having three more lines to I'm
buying all this stuff needlessly like I
just don't want to clutter the code up
too much so that's the reason why I'm
not doing that here okay so back in
application we still have this uniform
issue there's nothing really stopping us
from just doing this like we can still
do this and then we don't need to bind
any of that and then finally for the
renderer what I'm gonna do here is just
create a new instance of this renderer
class just like this render a renderer
and then over here we're just going to
call render a dog crawl we're gonna pass
in our vertex array when I pass in our
index buffer and we're gonna pass in our
shader just like that and so we're
basically telling our renderer here hey
I have a vertex ran an index buffer and
a shader please draw that onto the
screen and that's kind of what our
function does so if we come over here
and we actually run this application of
ours we're gonna get a whole bunch of
errors here because something's not
found it's probably because we're
actually including round
in here and then we're all best being
included into renderer as well so we
kind of got a cyclical include thing
going on here so let me go ahead and
check that vertex rankness that has
Buffalo because we do need that that is
a reference though so we could eliminate
that let's see if I think that I've got
a layout yeah is the reason this happens
is because the Vedic buffer layer calls
assert I think that's the only reason we
need renderer here isn't it
well actually we also include up in jail
okay sure so to kind of solve this what
we'll do is we will actually go to
vertex array dot H I'm not going to
include vertex buffer layout in here I'm
actually going to be forward to clarify
this type and class vertex buffer layout
like that and then in the CPP file I'm
going to include other things buffer
layout just like that so that way we
don't actually include vertex buffer
layout you hear the problem really is
that vertex buffer layout includes
renderer and then we include vertex
array which includes vertex buffer
layout inside renderer beige so it's
like we're including renderer in vertex
array and we're including vertex array
in renderer and it's kind of it's
getting into like an infinite loop of
inclusion well I'll have a C++ video
about that available at some point in my
life click there if it's there so if we
try and compile our code once again we
should be okay all right so back in
application of CPP we also have to
include that vertex buffer layout so
I'll include that like that
and compile our code all right there we
go succeeds let's go ahead and launch
this application see if we get the same
thing rendering and you can see that we
have the same result great few more
things that we can actually do to clean
this up is we have this GL clear here I
don't really want to do that here of
course so inside render o2h I'm just
gonna write clear and then inside the
CPP file I'm going to implement that
function clear and we'll just basically
copy and paste what we have inside
application which is color buffer bit
just like that and we'll just call
render or clear like that and to be a
little bit more correct what I'm going
to do is
this function as Const because of course
it doesn't do anything doesn't get it
over constrained or anything like that
and if we go back to application let's
just see what we've done so essentially
what we've done is we've gotten rid of
every single GL call I think that we
have in this entire file yep and so what
we've done is that whole rendering
situation that we've had we've basically
changed we've made some kind of drawing
functions so that we can just call draw
with the appropriate data and then clear
if we actually want to clear our screen
we do still have this kind of issue here
with the shaders where we actually still
have to kind of bind the shader so that
we can set the uniform to whatever we
want every frame I not a big fan of
leaving that Cody here the only real way
to solve that there is because we should
like the way that you would solve that
is by using materials instead of shaders
so what we have in our draw function and
render robot draw we're taking in a
vertex array and index buffer and a
shader that's a bit weird in a more
traditional setup we'd be taking in like
you know vertex array whatever index
buffer that's all fine but then we'd be
taking in a material instead of an
actual shader and what a material is is
basically a shader plus a set of data so
a shader plus all of its uniforms
whether that be kind of render a
specific uniforms or kind of per object
uniforms like for example this
rectangles color would be like a kind of
per object uniform that we actually have
and that would be stored inside the
material alongside the shader and so
that way when we pass in the material to
the renderer the renderer will basically
bind the material meaning that it would
bind the shader and set up all the
uniforms that it needs to and then call
the draw function for our vertex array
our end index buffer and all of that
kind of stuff so that's how that's how
it should work
we don't have material 0 or anything
like that so for now we have to actually
if we want to modify a uniform for a
shader we have to do that ourselves
manually a little bit annoying we might
get into materials in the future we
definitely will in the game enter the
series not sure about opengl series but
we probably will have to though this is
gonna get pretty complicated pretty soon
so for all of you people who are
thinking this is getting there's a bit
simple so far it's gonna escalate pretty
quickly anyway that's pretty much the
renderer we now have a class that we can
keep adding to when we actually need to
render more and more things I can't wait
to get into the more complicated stuff
next time we're going to talk about
textures and how we can render text
and load textures and all of that stuff
and open jail and after that I think
what were we going to move on to things
like 3d models or cool I don't know
there's so much so much to do I think 3d
models is probably a good idea we
probably want to move on to some kind of
debugging interface as well and like a
GUI system so that we can play around
with that once we have 3d models we can
move on to lighting and cool stuff like
that we also need to do text rendering
at some point just gonna be a nightmare
of course I hate doing a text rendering
I might actually write a library
specifically to make text rendering
easier for this series because it's
really quite annoying and I don't really
want to deal with that but then on the
other hand I need to show you guys how
to actually make text rendering work
without using libraries so that's going
to be fun anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if did give me that like
button you can also help support this
series by going to patreon I'll come for
such the chatter huge thank you as
always to all of the supporters of all
of the videos that I make your on
YouTube because they wouldn't be here
without those wonderful people next time
textures I will see you next time next
time next time I'll just say that would
have been more often good bye
[Music]